hey what's going on it's pill / and it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
May 20th 2019 what's going on how are
you oh I'm in a good mood yes I am first
of all first of all your Boston Bruins
are in the Stanley Cup final everybody's
let me know it's not the standing Cup
Finals they trashed me like it's not the
NBA Finals that's all so [ __ ] seven
games
it's the final not finals there's only
one of them well then [ __ ] go write
the NBA you can't I love when people
like to be right about [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] like that like that like you all of
a sudden oh oh oh I guess you went to an
Ivy League school
it's anyway not anyways oh okay so oh
Jesus you know that that bare minimal
[ __ ] intelligent thing that people do
like they just just because they don't
mispronounce [ __ ] words and basic
conversation like I do all of a sudden
they [ __ ] look at me like they're a
Rhodes Scholar you know I don't want to
get arrogant here but correct me if I'm
wrong here listen to my podcast alright
not the other way around
anyway the Boston Bruins have advanced
to this daily cup final all right sweep
Carolina in the Eastern Conference
Finals [ __ ] those [ __ ] people anyway
cuz they they go to the staple every Sun
in the Bible Belt noneya like ice hockey
you're really into hoop even though most
of you are in the [ __ ] Klan figure
that one out never understood why to
swat a man down staffed like basketball
so much
yet does not like the black man figure
that one out I'm [ __ ] with you I'm
not gonna do that Hollywood thing okay
where I act like all the racism is just
down south okay it's right it's out here
- okay it's everywhere all right anyway
I'm just [ __ ] around I am very
excited that the do we we win one more
playoff series will we'll have one three
yeah but I say we I mean wait okay cuz I
take all the [ __ ] [ __ ] when we lose
hey Bill you don't play for the Patriots
well you could have fooled me when we
lost to the Giants I never got so many
[ __ ] phone calls and text messages in
my life after those two losses let's see
what the [ __ ] was I just talking yeah if
we win three out of four the last time
that that was done the only teams I
guess the only city that's ever done it
as far as I know was Detroit Detroit
I guess sometime in the 1930s the Red
Wings the Lions and the Tigers all
wanted to want it in the same year
granted there was like maybe 30 teams
total right there was probably like what
six [ __ ] Billy you're really gonna be
that country where you got to take it
away from Detroit now god bless him I
hope we joined the ranks of what the
[ __ ] they've already achieved how about
that but I have to tell you you know
watching this Blues San Jose series I
thought that San Jose was the odds-on
favorite they probably were and I would
have said that at the beginning of the
series that I would rather have played
San Jose but I gotta tell you out the
water floor I'm [ __ ] curves these
Blues are a problem they're big that
fast
you know they got [ __ ] I love today when
I was watching the game Game five that
the Blues just [ __ ] mopped the floor
with them Thank You person who didn't go
to Ivy League schools sorry would you go
to schools bill you'd go to an Ivy
League school whatever whatever you just
as dumb as me you know why why would you
why would you be listening this if you
weren't
huh think about that one let that one
rattle around you [ __ ] empty head
they actually I mean I can't say that
they they had game three one and then
they [ __ ] blew it they did let up the
goal but I just thought it was hilarious
in game five today that the the San Jose
Sharks fans were getting on the refs
it's like well you should be sending
them [ __ ] thank-you cards after
somehow all of them missing that hand
pass that led to an overtime goal and a
victory obviously the fact that you're
still in this series I like everybody
else in the hockey world for the most
part fully expected San Jose at home to
come back and take control of this
series be up three games to two going
down to st. Louis with two games left to
try and close it out and instead the
exact opposite has happened your st.
Louis Blues who've been in the league
since 1967
alright haven't sniffed a chance at
winning the Stanley Cup since what 1970
was that the Bobby your [ __ ] game was
at 72 thing might have been 72 I'm not
looking it up I don't give a [ __ ] it's
bent bass it's been 45 it's 47 or
[ __ ] 49 years all right and they're
great fans and if they weren't playing
my Bruins I would be rooting for them
it's gonna suck if I finally get to see
the brew the Blues win a [ __ ] Stanley
Cup championship and it's like when I
finally saw the Eagles win it they had
to beat the Patriots I didn't quite get
to enjoy it
obviously as much as I would have but
yeah I don't know I by no means as
saying the Bruins have this wrapped up
I'm just psyched we're in the final and
I know that it's gonna be a it's gonna
be a tough series but I got to tell you
the Blues they're big they're fast
I thought San Jose is the same way but
all of a sudden everybody seems like
they're hurt so we shall see now now
that I've said that now that I have run
rub the Blues blue
balls over there they got blue balls
from all the cups II never won okay I by
no means think this series is over in
fact I think if San Jose wins Game six
they're gonna win Game seven and simply
because they're playing the Blues and
this is what the Blues do to their fans
so if I'm a st. Louis Blues fan right
now right now I gotta be thinking they'd
better be closing this [ __ ] thing out
in Game six they got to close this
[ __ ] thing how about well Tarasenko
and that [ __ ] penalty shot like I we
came all the way out like yeah that ye
like he was gonna do all this [ __ ]
come in and do like 20 different moves
like Patrick Kane and try to undress the
guy and then he just [ __ ] all over
[ __ ] top shelfs I don't know what the
sound effect was for it I know it wasn't
either one of those if you don't believe
me sync that up with the highlight
Tarasenko came anyway we know he just he
just went top shelf I didn't think the
goal even [ __ ] moved it was over and
that put him up three to nothing and
then it just got ugly and then I don't
know I then one thing I don't like about
hockey is when you get your ass kicked
like that then people start going out
and just trying to hurt people Patrick
Kane cross-checking the [ __ ] goalie
that just said not Patrick Kane out what
the [ __ ] his name there the guy was on
Winnipeg and he got traded around the
league what the [ __ ] is he he's and not
only does Patrick's not Patrick shop or
Vanderkaay there you go Vander King I
hate that [ __ ] when did Steve Ott become
a [ __ ] what world does that guy
become a coach the way he played that's
[ __ ] hilarious and congratulations to
him I don't know what the hell he did to
turn his [ __ ] life around and now
he's telling people what they shouldn't
should be doing on the ice but that guy
that guy was straight up on a slap shot
having said that fun guy to watch on a
boring game your session will expire in
two minutes what does that mean oh I was
editing this [ __ ] thing here yet
another episode keep me log log out now
there we go
editing episode 405 of efforts for
family by well why is it called 405 bill
you've only it four stands for this
season so it's episode five if you need
to know I didn't know I didn't know for
the first three seasons oh like what why
is this see this is called 301 so look
at season three it's the first episode I
was like oh okay
[Music]
so anyway I will be watching that game
six I have not watched any of the NBA
playoffs I know that the Milwaukee Bucks
I think are still winning and surprise
surprise Golden State that's looking
like they're gonna beat everybody the
NBA's a [ __ ] worst that's the big
baby league nobodies stand in the paint
don't challenge people if a team beats
you then just join the team the next
time that's why I can't get into this
whole [ __ ] who's gonna get Zion it's
like who gives a [ __ ] it's not about who
who's gonna get him it's who's gonna get
him next
that guy is there for one contract and
that's it they were doing this whole
[ __ ] what if Chicago gets it well I've
of those they should have fun they got
three four years of what however long
the contracts are they all leave and
they pile on he's gonna end up on I
don't know Golden State or [ __ ] the
LA Lakers or something like that he's
not gonna he's not gonna you know these
kids today now they picked their teams
like they're going on vacation you know
I don't want to play there it's gonna be
chilly I don't understand why people
don't do it more like the NFL I mean I
don't begrudge what Golden State's doing
because it's legal God knows every with
Celtic
they did in 2008 it was our pylon team
then I'm just saying overall it's just
bad for the [ __ ] sport it would be
great if if everybody had a chance so
that's why out of the goodness of my
sports fan heart despite the fact that
they [ __ ] kicked my Celtics ass I am
rooting for the Milwaukee Bucks
you know like that's gonna happen
like they're gonna maybe they can get
make it to the finals the NBA Finals the
Stanley Cup final whatever we shall see
so did you guys hear any stories about
abortion jesus [ __ ] christ
the amount of coverage that that gets
first is like global warming you know
mother nature's abortion global abortion
that she's gonna do to us
everybody flipping out you know I can't
believe the level of people that think
they're smart in the way that they talk
about people in Alabama these in bed
redneck [ __ ] with everybody looking at
him like that that's a beautiful [ __ ]
state all right
it's it has a lot of positives and I
have to be honest with you like this
really no more [ __ ] I don't know i
I've actually traveled I'm like a lot of
[ __ ] people who've never been to
Alabama like if you you want to find a
racist person that it's not that hard
it's not that [ __ ] difficult if you
want to find a [ __ ] [ __ ] and anytime
anybody talked I like you I don't know I
don't know where I stand on all this
[ __ ] you know like a lot of things I see
both sides of the [ __ ] argument you
know what I mean everybody sits there
and it goes like you know you can use
protection and then people say dumb [ __ ]
like well you know caught you do realize
that condoms aren't a hundred percent
well you know that's why you're not
supposed to be [ __ ] before you get
married
here's the thing the Bible isn't all bad
does anybody have a
problem with the ten commandments the
seven deadly sins is one of my favorites
they don't even though I [ __ ] up all the
time there's a lot of good [ __ ] in there
treat others the way you want to be
treated then there's a lot of bad [ __ ]
but it's it's not all [ __ ] bed and
these people that are against this [ __ ]
are trying to live by the way the Bible
and the Bible says no premarital sex and
then all of us over here like a man
who's the church say what I could do
with my body man I'm gonna have sex well
alright well there you go
then you run the [ __ ] risk right I
love whenever they talk about abortion
then they always have to bring up like
rapes you know they'll say [ __ ] like I
saw literally somebody goes so you're
okay if a six-year-old gets raped by
your father and she can't have an
abortion it's like well first of all a
six-year-old can't get pregnant alright
it kind of helps if you actually do a
little bit of [ __ ] research right
before you before you say something like
that but like they always make it seem
like their rape cases like most
abortions are because of unprotected sex
during ah what kind of rapist use a
condom right meet most most abortions am
i [ __ ] crazy here and God forbid I
have a [ __ ] just ask a question here
most abortions aren't they because of
people bangin consensually and not using
protection or the condom breaks that's
my favorite thing the condom breaks yeah
and nobody notices you you notice when
the condom breaks right it's like you're
watching a football game at home and
then all of a sudden you're on the field
and you get tackled all of a sudden
there's a feeling right I see both sides
of it I don't understand why everybody
has to [ __ ] yell at each other
okay there's there's too many [ __ ]
people and you know I are as like when a
life begins and when it doesn't I have
no [ __ ] idea I don't know what that
means all I know
is that like when people say it isn't a
life it's like well if you'd leave it
alone it would be it would become one so
I am pro people being able to do
whatever they want to do that's what I
am but I but I am NOT to the point where
I don't think that it's a taking of a
life or the ending of a light it's the
ending of a life it is because if you
didn't do it there'd be a baby
so something got ended something ended
that baby's life and I think it was you
with your [ __ ] Hoover vacuum there
right some something happened and I
think that people that are pro that want
to say that it isn't because they don't
want to feel that they're involved in
something like that right they then
conversely oh Jesus I'm [ __ ] all I
don't even know where I am in this
argument now then you got other people
there saying that you know I don't know
I I agree that that it is the the taking
of a life I think it's the ending of a
depending on when you get it I it's it's
definitely the ending of a life you
ended a life a life was gonna happen and
you ended it you aborted it and I don't
think that people that are pro-choice
like to hear that they like the love
Zara it's not a [ __ ] it's not a life
those are really really you would agree
you you who only reads medical research
that agrees with your opinion that's all
that anybody does so I don't know I have
no idea what the thing is the number one
problem though is is there's too many
[ __ ] people and for some reason that
never seems to come up in the abortion
argument hey Dom I don't I don't get it
I don't know what but I really wish all
the screaming yelling would stop you
know the amount of [ __ ] idiots like I
think I just focus on the left cuz I'm
on the left
I just can't [ __ ] him the amount of
is I'm name-calling here
I'm name-calling them cuz they're on my
team all right
if you want somebody in Alabama to hear
your opinion okay you don't call them
rednecks and inbred flow you gotta treat
him with a certain level of respect and
I just I just for the life of me I just
don't [ __ ] understand you know that
and then screaming your point at
somebody God knows I tried that for a
couple of decades that doesn't work
either so I don't know and I also think
that there's a lot of people on the left
wagging their fingers about how [ __ ]
Republicans don't want to help out poor
people and all that type of [ __ ]
and all I have to say to lefties it's
like what are you doing to help out poor
people other than voting Democrat do you
get involved you know that's something
like I mean I guess I do benefits but
I'm not involved I have all these
[ __ ] ideas I have all these things
that I go you know talking to Duff the
other day I was making me think about
that I'm not involved and there's a lot
of people who aren't involved and
they're acting like they're involved
because they're tweeting and it's like
you're not doing anything and I think
what I've learned since around the year
2000 the direction that we're going in
is is basically what I think what my
last guest Duff was saying was basically
that people regular people have to go
out and get involved and help regular
people and you have to kind of
circumnavigate the whole political
corporate money-making thing which
hasn't been all bad you know I like a
flat-screen TV
I like having 7,000 channels you know it
hasn't all been bad there's just got to
be a better way to [ __ ] do it so what
does that have to do with abortion I
don't know I don't know I just saw a
bunch of people [ __ ] yelling about it
and tweeting about it
you know look at all of this [ __ ]
all of these [ __ ] people - let's not
talk about that why why don't we abort
talking about the abortion [ __ ]
here's a question I have you know for
all those people who say that it's it's
not the taking of a life if I murder a
pregnant woman do I get charged with the
double murder or do I get charged with a
murder and an unlawful abortion you know
how does that work at what point in the
in the pregnancy is it a person legally
I tried looking that up I couldn't find
it I'm not good with the internet there
here's another one that I don't get
right always say like you know if a guy
gave birth to [ __ ]
that's another crock of [ __ ] I can tell
you this if a guy gave birth the [ __ ]
up the way women would worm their
[ __ ] way into that they would they
would everything that they say this goes
on in a woman's body and guys yeah they
would flip that whole thing emotionally
do you have any idea what it's like to
be that disconnected during the
pregnancy you can just move around with
you oh you have to do with Aaron's you
lie they're asking for weird food they
would turn the whole [ __ ] thing on
its ear I guarantee you they would
that's one of the things that has bugged
me about women going like men should be
making laws about my body and it's like
well you know something you shouldn't be
making all the decisions about men and
women [ __ ] either by the way this is cos
it's um I don't I don't get oh this is
well this is what I wanted to get to
right well I want a good cool I don't
get this if
have dirty unprotected sex and they get
knocked up right they get pregnant and
the woman doesn't want to keep it but
the guy does huh
what happens it's they're gonna get rid
of it it's her body right hey buddy
go [ __ ] yourself and a guy I don't want
to do this I don't believe in go [ __ ]
yourself you done right now conversely
if you flip that right dirty [ __ ]
unprotected sex and they fight they get
pregnant right and she wants to keep it
but he doesn't it's like I don't want
that [ __ ] thing right she's having
the baby okay then what she has the baby
then it's their baby how is it our baby
when we don't make get to make the
decision about whether it lives a nut
how come if a man if a man says I don't
want that baby and she has the baby why
does the old money why can't he say to
the judge I didn't want that [ __ ]
thing she asked me if I wanted it I said
no don't want it why does he have to pay
yeah I'm just got to say ladies for all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] moaning and
complaining you really are sort of the
Roman Emperor and the whole thing thumbs
up thumbs down does it live it does it
not your decision all right
I don't know I I've kind of had it with
this whole [ __ ] you know I understand
women in third world second world third
world country women in first world
countries the level of complaining that
they're doing versus the lifestyle and
the level of power that they have it's
just it's not lining up the granite I
have a lot of issues with women which
you'd never guessed from my stand-up
history if
and some of this [ __ ] I say here but I
mean it's just like I can't tell you
this the appellees the most happy
married men that I know do not argue
with their wives whatever their wife
tells them to do they just do it they
just yes dear and no dear and when you
say that to these [ __ ] broads who are
all talking about equality they all dead
yeah
that's what the [ __ ] they want they want
a [ __ ] yes-man and I have found in my
marriage as cool is my wife is she's
[ __ ] the [ __ ] as cool as it gets my
life is easier if I just okay sounds
good sounds good
you know they're at they ask you your
opinion on things but they don't they
just want you to reinforce what the [ __ ]
it is that they want to do okay they
know how to run the house the same way
you know how to drive the car they don't
how to drive the car okay anyway your
honor she said do you want this baby I
said no I have it recorded here it
doesn't make a difference it's your baby
well what if I wanted it and she didn't
want well it's her body dude do I ever
win no you do not next case he's signing
up for a rat she's riding up front he's
in the back okay all right what do you
guys want from me did you want some
informed opinion on the abortion issue
because if you do yeah I'm telling you
right now you're on you're on the wrong
podcast you are on the wrong [ __ ]
podcast all I know is that if you have a
baby that's that's the priority
okay I'm gonna go first Oprah Winfrey
applause better old school show when a
man and a woman have a child what they
need to do is prioritize the child right
then you get the applause break
Oprah nods like something deep was said
you're getting condoms and you're
getting condoms you're getting four
laughs prophylactics all right here we
go
speaking of prophylactics let's do some
reads for the let's do some [ __ ] reads
yeah but before we do before we let's
put a little buffer between the between
the womb talk and the [ __ ]
advertising here Oh Billy freckles Oh
Billy no sunshine ain't no sunshine
ain't owing boo boo boo ain't no Pig man
I'm in some pain sorry um I have not
drank in 25 weeks next week next week 26
weeks half the year just like that hmm
don't drinking something right now for
all you know well you know that's
[ __ ] that's booze right there
it isn't is it 25 weeks no [ __ ] Bose
I like it man I actually I enjoy it I
have to the point now where I don't even
think about it I'm actually seeing two
bottles of unbelievable [ __ ] booze I
got a bottle of Pappy Van Winkle's and I
got a bottle of Kentucky I'll just
starin at me I got no interest you know
I mean it's like when you meet the right
woman you know and then you stare it at
a couple of hotties across the room in
[ __ ] those [ __ ] keep in my house I
can't give my house to you [ __ ] so I
can have dirty unprotected sex with you
and then you [ __ ] you take yep you
make all the decisions I'm already in
that boat how many boats does a man need
I'm sorry all right I have not drank in
25 [ __ ] weeks
and next week we 26 and then I'm then
I'm running downhill my record since I
started boozed in when I was 17 as far
as like keeping track I didn't drink I
367 days a year in two days so that's
what I'm setting my sights on I don't
know kind of start off with that and now
I'm just feeling like I think I'm done
done you know it's gonna take a few
years off or something like that and
then I don't know what occasionally have
a beer right I got to tell you you know
what it happened to me this past week I
[ __ ] fell into a depression
I have not been depressed and forever I
don't know what happened I think I got
burned out just working my ass off and
then I've just been trying to stay home
and then I didn't have that balance I
wasn't getting on stage or something
like that and then I then I just started
thinking like I don't ever want to work
I don't ever want to do anything I don't
want to leave the house so I just
started thinking that [ __ ] like I was
actually last night thinking like if I
didn't have a kid I would start drinking
again and just slowly drink and smoke
cigars and just check out at about 69 70
that's where I was at and then I was
just like what am i doing I need to go
out let's go out and have some fun so
last night me and the lovely Taniya went
out to the the the the wisdom I think
it's East LA and I watched some Pink
Floyd music being performed by this
incredible [ __ ] band with one of my
favorite drummers of all time friend of
the podcast Steven Parkins he was
playing all the Pink Floyd stuff and it
was really cool to watch him play it cuz
not only did he crush it it was so
different from his style which I think
he's one of the most original drummers
of all time and but watching him play
that stuff last night I kind of felt
like I was watching him when he was a
kid playing along to like
the records that he liked and and then
his style developed out of that so it
was really cool and then they just had
like I wish I knew the names of the
people they had some guitars who somehow
connected with Kid Rock he [ __ ] was
just it was unbelievable there was
another kid who could sing and play that
they brought in last second he blew me
away these three women that would just
all of them next-level singers and uh we
went there and you just sorted they had
like the psychedelic [ __ ] going on on
the ceiling I don't know I never
understood why people need drugs beyond
just seeing that you know the stuff last
night was exceptional cuz I got to be
honest with you most of the time when
I've been looking at stuff like that and
everybody's just like far out man like I
just been like all right you know some
designs those are some pretty basic you
know art 101 depth of perception you
know giving it a 3d feeling it's going
this way but it's going that way kind of
thing freak
I just never I know I'm a I'm a drinker
right I don't wanna sit there [ __ ] you
know trippin on some [ __ ] vegetable
you know watch it a test pattern alright
I'd rather be drinking yelling about a
game you know that has no bearing on my
life I would rather do that and that is
the Schism the Chisholm thus chasm
uneven how to say that word between
drinkers and druggers you know because
they always try to say that alcohol is a
drug it's like it's not a drug okay if
it's a drug it wouldn't be legal okay so
why don't you take that back to Alabama
you inbred redneck [ __ ] okay
here we go
no I know it's a drunk cuz I kind of cut
out sugar and now I can tell when
there's sugar and some [ __ ] if you're
looking at the [ __ ] crack pipe again
waited all the energy in this podcast oh
Jesus Christ you talk about a couple of
dead babies and all the sudden you
alright here we go into the advertising
Oh
him 66% of men start losing their hair
by age 35 once you've noticed thing hair
it can be too late
is that hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet yeah the
whole top my [ __ ] head the best way
to prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
some it's time to get a handle on those
precious locks I ask you do you want a
bald spot to pop up on your hairline or
your hairline to recede or do you want
to do something about it first why one
the guys turn to weird solutions or do
nothing when they can turn to medicine
and science well some people just aren't
good looking and they just figure well
you know is this really that much of a
difference and that's how I looked at it
not falling off a mountain here I'm
falling off a curb
all right solution for hims calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men there you go
get your hair back your skin clears up
you got your dick standing at attention
prescription solutions backed by science
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or long Pharmacy lines for hims connects
you to real doctors online which could
save you hours completely confidential
indiscreet answer a few quick questions
a doctor will review and if they
determine it's right for you can
prescribe you medicine medicate
medication to treat your hair loss that
is shipped directly to your door order
now my listeners can get started with
the hims complete hair kit for just $5
today right now
Weiss while supplies last and subject to
doctor's approval
see website for full details and safety
information this could cost hundreds if
you want if you went to the doctor or a
pharmacy somewhere else go to for hims
dot-com / / that's fo our h-i-m s.com /
/ for hims dot-com / birth than us it
was them worries
look whose barrel zip hiring used to be
had multiple job sites
stacks of resume a confusing reviewing
process but today hiring can be easy and
you only have to go to one place to get
it done zip grid up dot-com / / zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
machine matching technology zip Europe
scans thousands of resumes to find
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job acts
of applications come in come in and zip
recruiter analyzes each one and spots
light spotlights the top candidates so
you never miss a great match zip is so
effective that four to five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within the
first day and right now my listeners can
try fit for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruited comm / / that zip
recruited comm / / b you are r zip
dot-com / / the smartest way to hiya
alright lastly but not leastly
stamps.com no one has time to go to the
post office you're busy who's got time
for all that traffic parking lugging all
your mail packet mail and packages it's
a real hassle man so that's why you need
stamps comm one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps comm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office stamps comm brings all the
amazing services of the u.s. post office
right to your computer whether you're in
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
even a warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
online
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
just hand it to your mail carrier or
drop it in a mailbox it's that simple
with stamps comm you get five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail right now my slash our
listeners my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Burpee URR that stamps comm enter ber
there you go oh you know what my
daughter just woke up from her nap I
[ __ ] love that kid wrap this thing up
here in 22 minutes and I'm gonna go play
with the kiddo she's learned why
everybody you got to go to bed why
because you need to get you sleep and
then she goes why not she doesn't know
the difference why and why not I want a
ride horsey dis one she's putting it all
together she likes going to the grocery
store too which is funny alright protein
dear bill broccoli I've been trying to
do well in my my lazy vegetarianism
we're just like once a day I sort of
chow down on the meat although I had
eggs for breakfast and then I had a
little chicken already whatever I'm lazy
what do you want for me I highly
recommend finding a good protein to
supplement with your smoothies in the
morning if you're going meatless for two
out of three meals protein is what
really gets the brain working and a guy
like you needs a help you can get you're
looking really healthy these days thank
you keep the muscle and you'll live to
be a hundred love you and love the
podcasts yeah I got this maca powder
that I put in one of the smoothies
like I said I'm not going full veggie
here I'm just trying to you know I got
to live as long as I can with my kid you
know that's really the the reason for
all this other than the usual vanity or
that type of stuff but I got to be
around for I want to see you know what
she's gonna do make sure she's all right
and all of that type of stuff which is
why all these big issues in the world
scare me you know which is why we should
probably myself included I should try to
do you know something that never came
about I was gonna do something for like
public schools we had such a [ __ ]
pain in the ass trying to figure it out
it never happened I gotta get back on
that anyway plowing ahead here
supplementing my smoothies with with
broccoli Oh finding a good protein to
supplement your smoothies also I guess
it lucky I guess that's what you meant
by the way I do love broccoli I do love
cauliflower I love root vegetables I
actually really like vegetables I'm not
a break fruit guy I'm a fruit but I'm
not a big fruit guy I like bananas you
know I don't mind a handful of grapes
but I just don't like that I don't like
the way it makes me feel I don't like
that [ __ ] that's sort of rush I like
vegetables you eat them you're full you
feel chill you keep your head together
you know what I mean fruits like it like
it's like a crazy person that that's you
know emotionally unstable well what
happens still is that the way you're yet
there's sugars in natural sugars now
natural sugars are not bad for your body
provided that you don't have too many of
them all right cops called on copy dear
Billy baton you hear about a Mehta med
getting the cops called on him for a
joke
what no have you ever had cops show up
at a gig of yours no I did not wait a
minute how could they get
they're that fast was he working
somewhere for a week Florida man calls
police on comic Amedda med after Middle
East joke makes him uncomfortable the
comics like cracked that it only takes
one of us triggered an audience member
to report him to authorities a Florida
man
not enough stories start with that a
Florida man called police to report a
comedian of Middle Eastern descent Jesus
Christ he's American well everybody
relax
whom he believed had told a joke that
showed support for terrorism stand-up
comedian a Mehta med why he got to first
night who was of a Gyptian descent poked
fun at negative stereotypes of Muslim
during a set at off-the-hook comedy club
in Naples Florida on Saturday and I say
clap if you're from the Middle East
Ahmed's said according to a clip posted
on the club's Facebook page after a
smattering of cheers I'm ed slyly
responded all right we got a handful of
us in here nice but hey it only takes
one of us and then he paused to tell a
joke that was the joke oh Jesus Christ
at least one member of the audience
didn't get the punchline the man called
the Collier County Sheriff's Department
and told the deputy a temed was
organizing people of Middle Eastern
descent to possibly commit terrorism no
yet did that guy shoot an unarmed black
guy in a hoodie on the way to the
[ __ ] he said ok he said that's great
he said we can organize their own little
terrorist organization wait who said
this but this is really poorly written
or I'm dumb that's probably the sexy the
man called the Sheriff's Department told
the deputy and am ed was organizing
people of Middle Eastern descent to
possibly commit terrorism I guess this
is what the guy was saying two men said
he said that's great we can organize
their own
little terrorists organization and I
don't think that was right I mean it
really bothered me the caller said
according to the audio of the call
released by the Sheriff's Department and
I yelled out and the paddy wagon is
going to be for you outside
the man added my wife and I looked at
each other and we felt very
uncomfortable the caller told
authorities he was only at the club
because he was given free tickets Jesus
a med told NBC News on Wednesday that
the it only takes one of us lying is in
his regular act and never smart any
blowback yeah this is just stupid you
guys want to hear the call we got to do
this here I don't know greatest
technology how come this what do I get
and then I got a click on this [ __ ]
thing hang on hang on hang on oh this is
just him it at improv that's not at the
captain's jump off order of the [ __ ]
call Captain Hook's off the hook
what about doctor hook huh oh yeah oh
right well yep that's what people do
nowadays joke ain't cuz I'm stupid that
makes me feel uncomfortable I need to
call the police you know so that guy
wasted the police's time when they could
have been in Florida getting the Gator
off somebody's [ __ ] front yard or
maybe stopping some crazy white guy from
shooting an unarmed black guy they could
have been doing that but note that down
there it did dr. Hook's [ __ ] off the
hook comedy club alright lady with
potential sugar daddy quandary yeah
alright I love the honesty of this
already hey Bill I'm a 35 year old who's
single lives alone and works a full-time
gig I enjoy so I was really surprised
when an old flame showed up out of
nowhere and essentially told me told me
he didn't want to grow old alone and he
wants to make me his woman was it
Richard Gere did he come in wearing his
navy whites isn't that like a romantic
story and he gets you out of your job
I'll tell you I was so depressed the
other night if that [ __ ] guy showed
up I would have left I would have left
with them um I asked what that meant and
it sounded essentially like me being a
paid tour manager slash groupie for him
year round in exchange for companionship
slash sex alright so you got an old
boyfriend of yours who now is out there
touring oh he's a 50 year old musician
so I don't have any realistic
expectation as far as monogamy but I
have grown really custom to being
independent and not relying on anyone
else for financial support well then I
wouldn't do this also I can't get over
the fact that it feels like some weird
sort of prostitution so I'd love to know
what you and Nia would tell your
daughter if she came to you with
something like this forget my daughter
I'm telling you don't do this I'm in no
rush and I've been content to wait for
the right guy to come around but this is
one of those moments where I find myself
wondering if I should just settle
I would appreciate any insight you two
sweethearts could share thanks and go
enjoy your weekend don't do that don't
take the short money on this one like
you're doing great you're financially
supporting yourself wait for the right
person to come around you want it you
want to be with somebody that you're
gonna want to like you know grow old
with like I have that with Nia like I I
think about that a lot especially now
with all the working that I'm doing I
think about you know hopefully living
long enough to become a grandfather or
whatever but I think about you know when
I think about being old it's not a sad
thing
like I've found me having a manageable
work schedule maybe be like semi [ __ ]
retired and I just do like some Vegas
gig or some [ __ ]
and just sort of putts around the house
and they're going oh you gotta put on a
sweater you don't know just taking care
of me and we have our shows and I'll
hold their yarn is she [ __ ] knits
whatever the hell she wants to do he
can't put a price on that
all right and yeah I I wouldn't do that
I mean here's a good sign you're
entering a relationship that's not gonna
work
yet oddly you oddly feel like a
prostitute from the get-go
I feel bad for this guy because I know a
lot of people that have done the road
and are alone at that age he said he
didn't want to grow old alone you know
what and nowhere in there did he say
that you were the one for him so yeah I
[ __ ] that guy not [ __ ] that guy just
forget that guy you don't need to be
doing that you know all right
plus if he's gonna be out there running
around god that's just it's dangerous
all right ghosting a chick mid date oh
I've done that a couple of times not
proud of it not proud of it but I did it
and I did it not because I was being
mean I did it because I didn't know how
to get the [ __ ] out of there and that
was the easiest way I'm sure some women
have done it I feel bad that I did it
and I'm sure I paid for in a karmic way
all right dear Billy schmegle smegma
lips anymore look to see what that means
I know it's brutal and I already feel
bad enough about most of my body I don't
need to hear that okay I hope you can
weigh in on a little story that just
happened to me
I matched with this woman on tinder and
things were going our wrath I threw a
few jokes and she replied with tomorrow
is my birthday and I alluded to wanting
to hang out I thought why not
oh you look up in the sky before you
walk out the door tomorrow dude there
might be a piano coming down on you
anyways she said tomorrow's my birthday
I alluded to wanting to hang out I
thought why not I don't have anything
going on she was going to celebrate with
her family on Friday they wanted to meet
up for a beer on Saturday okay Lisa's
not her birthday fast-forward to say she
pets she messages me the location of the
bar and wants me to come because she's
lonely on her birthday oh is this her
birthday she wants is her birthday
weekend you saying it's her birthday all
right it's her birthday well back on her
birthday well as soon as I show up I buy
a beer and she wants to leave I should
have seen this as a red flag already
because I didn't even really get to know
her through one beer as soon as we get
into my car she tells me that we can't
go to her place as her son is home with
the date and that would be weird
it sounds also like there's some sort of
time issue here like there's another guy
that's what I would think like why I
didn't get to finish my drink you like
come on come on give me the dick she's
got to get back to her her other life
this is [ __ ] weird get out it's like
your [ __ ] ear piece came out of your
ear and I'm in the van she wants me to
pay for a hotel not even knowing
anything but her name and that she has a
grown son yes I know she was older but
she had the whole milf thing going on uh
well it could be that all the women know
what the [ __ ] they want I don't like
this at all at this point I'm a little
taken aback by the forward nasai as you
should be and having to suddenly foot
the bill for a hotel room that I don't
want to pay for
she won't even split it you know she's
that [ __ ] hungry for the D as a kids
say on Instagram the gram she changes
her mind shortly after I tell her I
don't even know her yet and wants to
drive 30 minutes away to a bar and a
more happening part of town now she
doesn't she wants to get away from the
guy that's not banging her anymore but
she hasn't broken up with yet I'm a
little irritated at this point and she
starts to say it's my birthday and we're
driving as we're driving she starts to
tell me
she wants more kids and criticizing me
for not having any first of all how the
[ __ ] did she end up in your car now all
that's running through my head now all
that's running through my head is to get
around in my car as fast as I can
exactly so I pull up to a gas station
and give her 20 bucks to say I need a
six-pack for later in the night you know
I'm gonna pump some gas oh my god that's
hilarious with a trip back to the bar to
the bar and back I watch her go in and
don't even swipe my card and pretend to
start pumping gas as soon as the coast
was clear I put the pump back got in my
car and drove away
and unmatched her on tinder so she
couldn't contact me so am I an [ __ ]
hear it dude no that's [ __ ] hilarious
and he gave a cab fare home okay you
gave and she's in a safe place she's out
of [ __ ] gas station it's a public
[ __ ] place oh my god that's hilarious
the gas station I left her at was only a
few blocks from the bar where we left
and there are plenty of ride shares in
the area as well it's also worth noting
I legitimately felt like she would be
the type of person to start hitting me
if I rejected her while driving thanks
and have a magical day
Casper oh my god that's hilarious dude I
gotta I gonna tell you something not
only was that net was that not bad you
handled that perfectly this this this
had so many [ __ ] red flags and you
don't know what's gonna happen you don't
know what she's gonna do and God knows
you know believe women whatever the [ __ ]
she says and there's something about her
I like you know you got to be able to
get the [ __ ] out here let's go to a
motel she wanted to get it done and then
if you wanted to get to know her fine
I'll get to know you why couldn't you
stay in that bar she's got to go thirty
minutes away
that's just wreaked of another guy
driving around trying to find her where
the [ __ ] is she why isn't she [ __ ]
her man on her birthday like that guy
isn't out there looking for the [ __ ] out
of here
and she seems like she had a kid real
young I don't know I think yeah I think
you did yeah I think you you did good
you did good son
it did real good and a gentleman too he
could have said I want a candy bar give
her a couple of bucks although she is
gonna walk out with the booze but you
paid for it yeah [ __ ] her good for you
god bless you sir god bless you
it's kind of leadership America needs
right now son is a [ __ ] boy okay I'm not
sure I know what that means hey Billy
loose lips I'm writing to you for a
little insight I am a mother of the aged
42 and my son at the age of 18 he's an
only child and and although his father
wasn't around I think I did a decent job
with him but you call him a [ __ ] boy I
made sure he got to school and if he
threw up I took him to the doctors I
don't know if it's his new friends or
just genetics from his father but ever
since he's been in college he's been
breaking hearts left and right me and
his stepfather parentheses he knows it
isn't his real father tried to raise him
to be a man and take responsibility for
his actions I'm hoping it's just a phase
and he's not becoming his biological
father he has a new girlfriend every
week and the longest he's held a
relationship was a month and a half
that's not really breaking hearts I mean
maybe a month and a half a woman can get
feelings enough to love you but I mean
if you're with a woman for a week I mean
give me a break he's he's banging I
never attended college so I don't know
if this is just college kids or what
whenever I try to talk to him it turns
into an argument slash fight and when
his stepfather tries to step in the
situation gets worse I'm afraid that I
released a heartless [ __ ] machine into
the world I don't care if he gets
married or not if all he wants to do is
[ __ ] so be it I just wish you wouldn't
break those poor girls hearts in the
process any insight would be appreciated
well yeah I think you're kind of
projecting how do you know he breaks
these women's hearts he's only with them
for a week you know I mean how hurt can
you get month and a half yet that's
[ __ ] up I guess but you're also
ignoring the fact that
he's a product of your upbringing which
you basically said you did a decent job
you made sure he went to school and if
he threw up you took him to the doctor's
I mean that sounds like I mean those are
your words that's kinda sounds like you
did the bare minimal hear from the
friends I have whose dad's our mom's
didn't stick around you know at the age
he's at they have to process that so
he's going through the process of that
and I don't know I've always had this
thing when you're in your 20s you're
kind of you're out there taking your
childhood out on people because you
don't know who you are yet and if you
had a good childhood and you were raised
right then you're probably doing good
things but if you had a bad childhood
you're out there hurting people not even
realizing it you know it just seems like
normal behavior you're doing what was
done to you whatever I know there's too
many variables here I would say I know
it's weird that when you try to talk to
him about and he starts flipping out I
don't know what's going on here but you
know if he was somebody for like if he's
[ __ ] telling him that he really likes
him he sees that there's gonna be a
relationship here then then yeah he
shouldn't be doing that but I have to be
honest you do a lot of a lot of people
don't have that skill set male or female
at the college age and people listening
you would be surprised but specifically
guys you'd be surprised what honesty
does with the woman if you just tell her
upfront what the [ __ ] it is you're doing
what are we doing well I'm between
relationships right now I'm not looking
to get in one so what do we we're just
having fun
yeah so you don't like me well I like
you I just don't like you like that why
not I I don't know it's just one of you
can you just answer them honestly and
you'd be surprised the amount of times
that they'll hang out and sort of you
know still hook up with you it's weird
but you always have to watch out with
women cuz then you don't know if you got
one
oh you know once he hits this he'll be
[ __ ] you know loving me or whatever
good could be something like that or I
just was just thinking of Mia just
rolling her eyes at me that I just said
that but all right I'm gonna close with
the art of the fuck-buddy okay there's
the art of war is the war of art and
there's the art of the fuck-buddy the
art of the fuck-buddy is that what
you're doing is neither one of you wants
to catch feelings neither one of you
wants to be in a relationship so what
you have to do is there has to be a
there has to be time between hookups
okay
you have to use protection and then you
do the deed you know just get up and run
out of there but you get the [ __ ] out of
there soon you don't hang out and watch
a [ __ ] movie you don't go out to
dinner you are [ __ ] buddies you are
buddies who [ __ ] that's it all right
yeah then you get the [ __ ] out you get
away from each other then you [ __ ] off
for a while that's it
you [ __ ] off for a while you know I'd
say at least 10 days at least 10 days no
[ __ ] contact no nothing you'd be
surprised how [ __ ] cool women are
when you're [ __ ] honest with them I
wish I learned it at a younger age you
could literally set something up all
right let's just be [ __ ] buddies twice a
month that way nobody catches any
feelings that's it all right
Tuesday night every other Tuesday cool
but only Tuesday night and if either
other person cancels then it's gonna be
another two weeks that way nobody gets
[ __ ] hurt there you go you get both
got an ace and a hole hey who knows that
probably still ends up getting [ __ ] it
always ends up getting [ __ ] up anyways
that is that is anyway that's the
podcast congratulations to the Bruins in
the Stanley Cup final congratulations
the Golden State Warriors as they roll
along to a NBA Finals
and go blues I want to see the Blues I
want to see you make it to the finals
we'll have a rematch rematch of the 1970
or the 72 I might as well look it up now
right
the Bruins 1970 cup first who did they
play the Stanley Cup Finals National
Hockey League the Bruins are the st.
Louis Blues it was 1970s so they haven't
been there in 49 [ __ ] years you got a
route for the Blues right I have to root
for my Bruins cuz they're my team but
anybody else you got a room for the
Blues they got that big of a drought
they've never [ __ ] won it 53 seasons
52 years think about that there's people
that were like in their teens and went
to that first st. Louis Blues game
alright and now they're pushing 70 you
were 17 [ __ ] years old you've now be
69 so if you're eight anybody 18 or
older is at least 70 years old been
waiting and waiting and waiting and
[ __ ] waiting Vietnam War ended
Grenada
the first Iraqi war spuds Mackenzie
think of all the things that happened
this never-ending [ __ ] conflict
whatever the hell were involved in cell
phones we get a pill was a long time all
right I don't what the [ __ ] to tell you
all right that is the podcast you know
what I went do tonight I'm gonna [ __ ]
go down to the comedy store try some
abortion material alright and you know
what I guarantee you there's gonna be a
Florida man who's on vacations gonna
have a difficult time with it it's gonna
have a difficult time but but that's not
how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it to
make fun you know what I want to do I'm
gonna go down to LA go [ __ ] Ground
Zero of liberals and I want to go down
there and I want to
Oana I'm gonna do jokes that are
pro-life
it's not the taking of a life is it well
after the procedure where'd the baby go
what happened
it's that baby it are you a doctor you a
medical person and they'll be like are
you and I'll be like no I'm not but can
you tell me you know something happened
it's good it's good for the puppy'll
it's good for the Rainforest abortions
good for the rainforest that's what they
need to do they need to get these these
people in Alabama who loved to hunt they
love the fish they love getting out
there and going after them ducks right
to get him on board you got to bring you
got to tell them that if you kill these
babies that cuz there's gonna be more
trap it's gonna be more bark all right
pheasants should only [ __ ] that they
love to shoot it's all gonna [ __ ] go
away I got something else how about we
go liberal huntin how about that [ __ ]
get me a license I'll [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
shoot him from a hair all the way to
[ __ ] Boston Massachusetts there has to
be a way they also asked him why is it
why is there only two sides to an
argument you know it's gotta be that
third side is there what's the third
side we just walk away and say man I
can't listen to this anymore uh we are
an extra time here in the podcast and it
is not going well all right go [ __ ]
yourselves a check on Thursday good luck
to the blues